hey you guys and thanks for tuning in to
ET live on our Facebook page
Sean hook is here today so make sure
that you're sending in all of your
questions we're gonna get them right
here on this snazzy iPad I hope yeah
some good ones I hope so too
don't be afraid some real hot button may
be embarrassing okay be afraid that's
what I'm looking for we are also going
to talk all about your new EP my side of
the story so first of all why did you
call it my side of the story and what
did you want to convey yes it's my side
of your story so there's a bit of like a
twist on it you know when I put the EP
together a lot of the songs had to deal
with late dealt with relationships yeah
and there's narrative in my songwriting
and I thought my side of your story was
kind of what it was all about from my
perspective so are you setting the
record straight with any of your past
and did you get any angry phone calls no
no angry phone calls actually just yeah
one of my exes reached out to me I was
like oh my god I'm so proud of you and I
don't think she knows what like the
songs are about no I don't write and
tell I don't write and tell okay yes yes
I also saw in your Instagram that you
are releasing something this Friday
yeah that pertaining to this album or
what can you tell us just so except no
no just some exciting news it's not it's
not a new music per se it's just some
exciting news about upcoming appearance
okay
yes let's talk about the first single
with Vanessa Hudgens reminding me I mean
the video is so steamy the song is so
good and it was kind of her return to
music it was like four years yeah so how
did you get her on this song how did you
get her to say yes well we have mutual
friends and we live in the same part of
town here in Los Angeles and we've
crossed paths before when I wrote
reminded me I've wrote it as just a solo
song but I thought for the EP would be
great if I had a feature on one of my
records and reminded me was kind of a
lends itself well to a duet and Vanessa
was on my top list and I reached out to
one of our mutual friends and she heard
the song we set up a coffee meeting we
went from there is the mutual friend
someone that we would know no I don't
think so
now no one behind this behind-the-scenes
okay yeah and had you seen a High School
Musical and were you a fan no I haven't
and I'm I I should watch it now it's a
great movie that's right no I know what
was your first impression of her like
then she was amazing you know we suffer
coffee I'm pretty punctual so I showed
up at 129 for a 1:30 meeting and she was
already there with a coffee in her hand
and I was like wow that's that's a good
impression
yeah when someone can show up early and
they're punctual that's that's great
so it was great can we talk about the
video did you come up with a concept did
you guys collaboratively come up with a
concept er or how did that work it was
actually the director a attend Amira
she's amazing and I met a probably three
four years ago when she was doing lyric
videos for Katy Perry and last year I
ran into her at a party and she saw my
last music video sound of your heart and
she's like Sean I would love to work on
your next video and so reminding me came
out and she wrote the treatment and she
asked me what I had in mind and I didn't
I didn't want to give her any kind of
boundaries I just said listen I wanna
these these are kind of the the
parameters I want I want a an edgy sexy
classy looking beautiful cinematography
kind of video and she kind of ran with
that and came up with the treatment is
that why you went for the whole
black-and-white yeah was that you or was
that that was that was her she pitched
it to us like that and I was like you
you've got it you nailed it yeah and one
small thing we had to change initially
we're gonna shoot it at the Chateau
Marmont but we couldn't get in there
during our schedules so we got the the
Goldstein house which is beautiful
where they shot the Big Lebowski and
yeah thank God how long did the process
take you guys was it a couple days of
shooting you were saying it was very
quick it was it was really fast and it's
super prepared so we only shot each
scene maybe once or twice and we went on
to the next and the next to the next
because we were only there for about 11
hours it was a strict cutoff and we
actually got cut an hour early cuz the
fire marshals like alright you guys have
to be out of here by 11:00 we're like I
thought we had it till midnight but
yeah we got it thank God you guys got it
okay let's talk about the scenes at the
very end when you guys are in bed
together did you worry about what Austin
Butler was going to think Austin's
awesome actually my girlfriend met
Austin before before Vanessa and I had
met okay yeah so it wasn't actually
respectful the thing that was crazy that
was the first scene we shot together so
we show up in our under I was so awkward
on each other's parts like we're just
because there's people in the crew
watching us and we're trying to be as
intimate as we can in this moment
portray the characters in the video so
it's pretty awkward but we got through
that be honest how many times did you
guys actually laugh or break character
while filming that a lot for the first
five minutes and Vanessa's got this
nervous thing where she winks when she's
nervous and then she would start
laughing then I would start laughing
that'd be like okay cut cut can we just
try and get like a minute worth of
footage where you guys are just
passionate right but eventually we got
it that's such a fun quick to have it's
like a winking because you don't know if
she's trying to be sexy or if she's
doing that because she's having anxiety
or something yeah no is it's funny we
got we got through I think that made us
more comfortable and then we were able
to go on with the rest of the day yeah
do you have a next single in mind yeah
there's a couple songs on the on the EP
my side of your story one of them I want
to put a more of an up-tempo song and
there's one called never let me let you
go yeah and I'm thinking that might be
potentially my next one if I have any
say yeah do you not say no I do I have a
great team of people that I work with
and I really the reason why I am where I
am is because there are team of people
that that I respect and I respect their
decisions and so it'll be it'll be a
community decision committee decisions
how has your journey because I feel like
2016 was such a big year for you that
first single yeah so how has life
changed for you since that came out and
what's been the most maybe challenging
hurdle yeah you know what 2016 was crazy
and I was kind of only known in Canada
before that and because sandy heart was
so successful inside and outside of
Canada it opened up a lot of doors for
me not only in the in
serene what the fans are hearing but
also in the song of the community I grew
up writing all my own songs and I'm a
songwriter as well as an artist and I
was able to collaborate with Ryan Tedder
on this record and Omar Malek and Jay
cash all these big level songwriters and
that really opened the door and kind of
changed the game for me okay be honest
did Ryan Tedder tell you anything about
Taylor Swift's new music no nothing no
not at all well because they've worked
together before and so I didn't know if
maybe you had some fun no we know we did
it we just kind of got in the studio and
got to work and and wrote dancing the
sky and I was he's got incredible an
incredible studio and I have incredible
studio Envy yeah cuz you walk down and
you see all his plaques all those are
boards and and you know all the artists
he's worked with at that same studio
like Adele Taylor Swift room five list
goes on and on and on yeah so that was a
cool experience and I really did hit it
off hit it off with him and super stoked
on the song well you've worked with some
really cool people so who else is on
your bucket list
bucket list that's a good one I would
love to work with Eminem I think he's
that isn't the best answer sorry genius
and he's incredible and I don't know if
it'll ever happen but I'm just gonna
throw it out there I would love to work
with him I think that that would be so
cool yeah we made music no not a bit in
a while but obviously you're good at
getting people we'll see I don't know
surprise music industry yeah it's small
you mentioned your girlfriend's so how
is dating and being in the spotlight is
it harder yeah easier how does she
handle the fame and and girls coming up
yeah it's challenging and I have so much
respect for her and because it's my
schedule I'm always on the road and I'm
always in a different place and after a
show there's girls and people I'm
meeting and talking to and interacting
with and it takes away from our time
together but when we have our time
together it's it's amazing and she's a
huge support of what I do and I'm a big
supporter of what she does and if we
make it work but it takes it takes a
special someone and thankfully I have
her we met the Gripp stop yeah before
the DM slide came into use
so so did you comment on her pictures or
yes I had a show at Hotel cafe and one
of our mutual friends posted a picture
of us together and she followed me and I
was like oh it was kind of cute so I
followed her back and there was a series
of insta flirting for like two months on
pictures and then we took it to Facebook
because I actually was living in Miami
but she was from Portland Oregon and I
shot a music video there and I guess
someone importantly posted something and
monks very short network never now when
I Adam is she la bass now she's now yes
she's now la baby funny
all right well speaking of touring and
being on the road do we have plans I
know that you have some upcoming gigs
radio yeah promotional shows but what
about a tour for you working on working
on the tour I was just talking to my
agents yesterday and hoping to go into
her in November there's a couple there's
a couple options but we're just planning
on planning it out but from then on I do
have some tomorrow flying up to
Minneapolis I have a radio show there
and then there's a couple shows in
Canada and Germany so yeah it's gonna be
a fun life on the road yeah when you're
on the road are you still continuously
writing and do you have plans for a
full-length album yeah yes yes yes yes I
have I wrote probably 80 over 80 songs
for the four songs ep so there's a lot
of material that is already written and
I'm still running until the labels like
alright yeah we have the record but I
think we're gonna try put out of another
EP or an extension to the EP in the fall
okay wait 80 songs yeah so how do you
narrow it down to these four it's a
tough choice yeah because when you
create something it's like it's yours
and you want to put it out there and
like I said earlier you know I have a
team of people that I trust and I'm
always looking for other people's
opinions and inside and outside of
industry and and kind of do a little
survey within my circle and see what
people like and usually the great ones
go to the top and that's kind of what we
take to the beach yeah what's the most
personal subject matter in any of your
songs that you've covered and why was it
important for you to cover that I mean I
try to put that in every single song
because if I don't if I'm not true in my
music
it's there's no point in turning me
anyways to put up music I think as a
writer I wear my heart on my sleeve and
the my best songs were my most emotional
most personal songs one of my early
songs that wasn't ever released on a
major label but was a song I wrote
called soldier and it was about a lady
who lost her husband and he was serving
in Iraq and at his funeral there were
protesters and it was it was awful what
there was Westbrook Westboro Baptist
Church were protesting his funeral and
at that time I had just moved out from
home and I really missed my family and I
was like I couldn't believe what someone
my age must be feeling away from their
families and just kind of struck a chord
with me and after seeing the news piece
but Brandi Seco in Topeka Kansas I was
like you know what this is something I
really want to speak about and I wrote
about respect it wasn't it wasn't
political it was just respecting a
fallen soldier yeah I'm sure the family
appreciated that do they ever know that
it was about I've never talked to Brandi
herself but it became kind of a I don't
wanna say an anthem it became a song
that this soldiers communities of
families shared and I was reached out to
from people who said hey I played your
song at my son's funeral and it just
brought it was brought tears to my eyes
yeah and this you know I wrote it for
that purpose just it's it's respect
these people and yeah as a song I
there's no higher compliment no I mean
that's that's an incredible story where
is your place in the music industry
where is my place yeah what do you think
it is that's a good question I don't
know I mean it this industry is just
changing so much the way people are
consuming music and it's so fast and we
get judged kind of based on the last
thing we've done and put out I don't
know I'm still trying to make my place I
guess in a lot of ways you know my
career arc hasn't been exponential it's
been very kind of up and down and I'd
say linear but I'm still making my place
I'm a songwriter I love performing live
and I don't know this is what I am you
tell me cuz you brought up the way that
the music industry has changed in the
way that we consume music and with
streaming and with Spotify how is that
affect
artists like yourself do you think it
makes it harder or easier it's it's it's
interesting I think that's you can
answer that in many ways I think it's
good in general because that's the way
we're moving that's the way people
that's the way we want to consume things
now yeah we watch TV shows we want to do
it on demand when we listen to we want
to make our own playlist it's
customizable it's the way technology is
driving now music industry is still
trying to catch up to that and find out
how we can monetize now Spotify is great
in the accessibility for people but as a
songwriter they still haven't figured
out how to distribute the the money the
revenue properly because there's a lot
of song winners that are struggling and
a lot of my friends are struggling and
they're they have hits to their name but
they're struggling because the old
revenue streams of mechanical sales and
radio play aren't as much as they used
to be and we're still as a songwriting
community trying to find out how to
disperse that right I always hear
stories similar to what you were saying
it was someone I think she used to be in
the Pussycat Dolls and she was saying I
was on tour with Christina Aguilera and
I couldn't even afford a Starbucks
Coffee yeah and I was like that's so
gnarly
yeah it's reality and it's kind of
because we think you know we think of
artists that have success that we hear
in the radio we see on TV like oh they
must be doing really well but there's so
much behind it there's there's teams you
have to pay for there's other expenses
and and yeah there's a lot more to it
but the thing for me I don't try to
focus on that as much it's a passion I'm
so thankful that people listen to my
music and I get to do what I do every
day and I think it's a good thing that
technology is bringing music to people
when they want it yeah totally Isaac
says what is your favorite singing group
favorite singing group well I think the
Eagles are a band but I think their
harmonies together we're amazing yeah
the Eagles that's a good answer
yeah karen says musical inspirations
well I grew up listen it's funny I grew
up listening to the country music I'm
from a small town in Canada but I really
got into the Beatles and Queen Freddie
Mercury is incredible I just listening
to Jeff Buckley last night I got a new
record player he's an incredible singer
Prince Paul McCartney
Bryan Adams in Canada he's incredible
artist a lot of classic happening here
yeah okay yeah
Bryan says what about your favorite
country singer favorite country singer
ever
that's a good question well I know
Johnny Cash kind of walked a line
between like no pun intended
between country and [ __ ] with Johnny
Cash was a huge inspiration for me and I
guess you can put him in the country
umbrella yeah Brett says will never let
me let you go be a single oh that was
yeah yeah if I have a choice and if my
team is listening it will be yes I think
your team is listening yes that's gonna
be the I will direct them to this
Facebook live like after yeah Thank You
Brit um we're gonna play a lightning
round with you oh I'm not gonna lighting
rounds this is gonna be fun no this
one's good okay all right first the
level you got starstruck by Pamela
Anderson was not expecting that second
part of that answer okay
what was when Google first came out with
around that time that was one of my
first girls Pamela Anderson Baywatch
yep yeah in the red okay um first big
purchase that you made after making it
big I guess I got a car I had the same
car for 13 years it was dying it was
costing me more money to fix like the
a/c unit and like I was like you know
what I really need a car yeah I got a
car what a good story finally made him a
car alright song currently on the radio
that you wish you had written oh it's a
great question I hope you say dis fussy
you do actually know I really like slow
hands by Neil horn that's a great song
good song I really like the effect that
the engine mixer used on his voice it's
like this dry gated reverb yeah okay um
lyric that you were most proud of of
reminding me I really like the first
line because it totally paints the
picture of what the song is about wine
she's spitting out the wine I forgot you
left behind like right there you know
what this song about
so I'm proud of that I feel like all the
lyrics in that song are pretty good
because they kind of just hit you thank
you yeah in the gut all right you've
broken one Guinness World Record so if
you could break another what would it be
for something music related ah hopefully
in a good way yeah like most streams or
most single soul something like that
yeah yeah and before I ask you this
final one we're gonna get a few more of
these okay cool going jessica says soul
music influence I guess
Marvin Gaye yeah going back to that
whole club Yeah right they didn't have
distractions they weren't trying to be
anybody else they were just pure and
they were themselves and yeah yeah come
on old soul Isaac says what is your
favorite music film music film um well
actually I like August Rush but I what's
the journalists one um oh my god I'm
blanking on the name Oh almost famous
yes almost famous uh-huh that story it's
one of the best movies yeah Sammy says
if you were not in the music industry
what would you be doing well I grew up
playing a lot of sports and growing up
in Canada I used to play hockey and when
I was a kid I was I was my goal I'm
gonna make a child one day yeah then I
didn't grow it's not like way after I
was out of hockey and that didn't happen
so I guess I don't know I guess I
couldn't be a pro athlete but it'd be
maybe something in sports or teaching
music okay you still play hockey yeah
for fun and golf okay yeah
and finally three reasons why people
should get this EP well if you like
great music you will be satisfied that's
one good reason to see the first reason
and three because it's it's it's good
you're gonna enjoy it is good I promise
I listen to all of it and it's great and
it's catchy I have to come up with a bit
I'm not I'm not a good salesman
I'll do for you to stick to the singing
it's a good album thank you so much for
joining us thank you my pleasure you
guys for tuning in make sure that you
follow
tea here on Facebook and all of our
socials make sure that you keep up with
Sean on his Twitter his Facebook his
Instagram and we'll see you next time
thanks for watching
[Music]